[Musique]
dans toutes ces choses il ya aussi
faisait perdre une classe cirque la
hausse je vous vois ne vous ne bougeait
plus et vous ne parlez plus un petit bug
de connexion lors de sa discussion avec
le fondateur du forum klaus schwab pour
un très long moment de solitude capturé
par un journaliste
qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est pas nous qui
avons des problèmes [ __ ] pourquoi tu
fais ça là sérieux elle est belle la
technologie là je te jure la main elle
part avec sa tête et son couteau
après une minute d'attentes la
conversation a pu reprendre
le gouvernement réfléchit à prolonger
les vacances d'hiver pour freiner la
circulation du virus
ils sont toute la journée ensemble halak
en chine sont tout le temps collée dans
les classes et pas une semaine qui va
changer quelque chose c'est ridicule en
plus de me faire le monde comme rcb je
paye nous en plus encore
et monsieur macro si les décisions
avaient été prises autrement
plutôt que de nous faire miroiter des
ouvertures à certaines dates
les dégâts ne serait pas aussi important
que simple ce restaurateur niçois a
décidé d'ouvrir son établissement
en dépit de toutes les règles sanitaires
en vigueur je moi je lâche seul élément
déclencheur si ça peut donner la force
et le courage notamment restaurateurs
[Applaudissements]
le patron a servi ainsi près d'une
centaine de repas dans une ambiance
festive pas de masque ni de protocole
sanitaire c'est une action de
désobéissance assumer alalou de la
liberté justement cette assiette mais la
liberté 1
la préfecture a annoncé que les
personnes présentes avaient été ou
seront verbalisés le restaurateur lui a
été placé en garde à vue pour avoir
employé un cuisinier étrangers en
situation irrégulière
[Musique]
c'est un grand chef au chapeau noir et
andy thayer va me chercher la salade
donc je lui amène les caisses de sattouf
hier se battait dans un trois étoiles
michelin et il ouvre le bac ivoirien
fait t'as vu comment la salade et je lui
réponds je te promets chef comme on tue
à l'eau chaude vous l'avez pas le cas
lucho debout l'information fait froid
dans le bas du dos la chine effectué des
tests recto pour détecter le coc vide
selon des médias nationaux les habitants
de plusieurs quartiers de pékin ont dû
s'y soumettre
tout comme des touristes étrangers
placés en quarantaine lubrifiants gels
autres liquides aux passes
certains évoquent un test peu douloureux
mais super humiliant des études montrent
que le dépistage rectal et plus
efficaces que les pcr classique mais
pour des raisons pratiques il n'a pas
vocation à être généralisée
la première chose que tu feras quand tu
remontera sur scène je pense que je vais
chalet comme une merde on donne du
bonheur au public pas au milieu humide
on est des marchands de bonheur quoi
tuer et à l'âge que j'ai v6 dans deux
jours ça sera trop tard
voilà mais on est en train de culte
spectacle on est mort nous font chier
quel message aimerais-tu faire passer au
gouvernement s'il vous plaît je crois
qu'on a un peu plus essentielle que ce
que vous pensez on existe les artistes
la culture ya quelqu'un à l'eau à l'eau
la terre et tous les médecins au 6 juin
anxiogène east ils sont pour quelque
chose mais je les emmerde jeu-là
survivre et pour vous avez posé vacciner
ma famille est contre je le sais bien
mais il faut vacciner une puce sous la
peau pour tracer et contrôler la
population mondiale d'où ça vient ça
ainhoa et des journées aucune idée je ne
sais pas d'où ça vient
on fait partie des complotistes mais
vous êtes fous au cours non je vous pose
la question mais je vois comment les
regarder vous robert beynat
il ne croit pas à l'efficacité des
vaccins c'est les abrutis qui vous
disent faut pas se vacciner rien de ce
que en quoi je suis impliqué à
n'implique des puces en attendant sous
la peau des gens et de suivre les jeunes
je comprends pas la logique pourquoi est
ce que je serai impliqué là dedans
notre fondation fait des vaccinations
effets des vaccins pour sauver des vies
et chérie j'ai mal aux yeux
je vous ai expliqué pourquoi il paraît
que c'est à cause du masque ce que je
porte le masque toute la journée et que
ça remonte dans les yeux et ça me fait
des allergies c'est la laine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est un petit peu comme les
télétubbies je ne sais pas si vous vous
rappelez les télétubbies pour les petits
le reportage passé cette fois d'affilée
pour qu'il comprenne c'est ce que nous
faisons un peu nous remet un peu l'étau
bêtise c'est différent mais voilà des
nouvelles révélations indiquerait que du
riz était muni d'un tournevis le soir de
son agression et qu'il serait connu des
services de police et évidemment c'est
un élément qui interrogeait les
enquêteurs des investigations auraient
aussi été menées à l'encontre de sa mère
comme le dévoile le journal libération
nathalie a été créée par onze femmes
franco-ukrainienne de travail dissimulé
du travail illégal et de traite des
êtres humains le chat tu jusqu'à 1
milliards d'oiseaux 3 milliards
d'animaux par an monsieur lombaires vous
avez un problème avec les chats j'ai
remarqué qu'ils aient nombreux
amendements qui indique que vous avez un
vrai problème avec les chats je n'ai pas
de problème avec ses chats si à chaque
fois que je parle de chat ceci cause
problème à monsieur le rapporteur et
bien que ils prennent une tisane ça le
calmera
il ya un nombre qui s'est fait tabasser
et on vient nous expliquer un truc qui
démontrait g
à ce moment là je trouve ça scandaleux
ça me révolte je vous dit votre plus que
vous faites maintenant ça me révolte je
me caille public sur les yeux c'est nul
je pense que je veux surtout le vertueux
on a des vocations
je vais manger mais pas comme jeu
je vous explique pas venir nous parler
d'un poil judiciaire effectivement très
grave
on nous le sang au moment où un homme
s'est fait défoncer la gueule et coups
de marteau je m'en fous de savoir ce qui
s'est passé avant ou après mais on parle
et c'est ouf c'est benjamin castaldi que
vous savez que ces femmes là en
l'occurrence c'est pas le problème
d'aujourd'hui la gueule quand on entend
que les îles
bah bien jeter fricker du cyanure et en
trucs comme ça sur le vini sur les i en
fait il ya ma casquette que je porte à
l'époque avec le nom du magasin qu'elle
sait que le piercing que je porte le
trader est ce que je veux fumer entre
huit et quinze jours si vous voulez
récupérer votre enfant votre pardon
autre animal un mot qui témoin une
commande de l'attachement que je peux
avoir pour les animaux vous l'aurez
compris ayant fait sept ans on tape sur
la deuxième pour ma part je le voterai
après une réunion de la conférence
feeling avec mécha juju savons qu'ils
m'ont donné autorisation de voter le
ditex et jouant en remercie